what's up guys my name is the channel
welcome back to my code review series
the series in which you guys send me
your suspicious projects and I take a
look at them today we're going to be
taking a look at a 2d physics engine in
C plus sent To Us by story 21 years old
and the second in the second in the
third in this third
I don't know why it's so funny year of a
games programming school or my last
project last year was to do a 2d physics
engine in cbos plus the base fit was
made following the video designing for
600 in five minutes if you guys haven't
seen this video by the way I do
recommend it the thing about physics
engines is that they seem like really
complicated things like a physics engine
like that's got to be so much work but
to be honest like at at its core it's
actually surprisingly simple now of
course if you go into like 3D physics
and you're talking about like the whole
kind of Suite of tools that you might
have inside a physics engine like you
know fluid dynamics cloth simulation
hair all of that together does amount to
pretty complex code however a simple 2D
physics engine is honestly something
that I recommend as like a potential
exercise if you're a beginner or
intermediate or even Advanced programmer
and you've never done it before because
it's a really fun and I guess useful
learning experience and this designing a
physics 105 minutes is a really good
place to start I'll leave that video
linked below and this person has also
added some broad face Collision
detection which is pretty cool so we've
got Circle colliders ABB access line
bounding box colliders and Broad face
Collision detection with a grid so
that's cool so I'm assuming there's some
kind of like probably like a quad tree
or some kind of like it doesn't even
have to necessarily be a quad tree could
just be like a grid kind of spatial
partitioning system so that we can only
kind of collide the colliders that are
that are close to each other that are
even possible to kind of collide with
each other and that of course will
simplify a lot of the kind of object
versus object Collision test that you'll
have to do since it will massively
reduce the number of tests you have to
do and that tends to be a huge
bottleneck if you just have a lot of
objects in your scene the engine set up
as a CMAC library and there's a demo
project to showcase the engine using
sfml cool the dependency is fetched
using fresh content so everything should
just work I like things that just work
feedback I'm looking for scalability
slash performance I try to write this
code the best that I could but I know
it's not perfect and I'd appreciate if
you could give feedback as if this was a
bigger project where these two points
are important okay I love that this
person actually specified this because
last episode or like that just in
general in this code review series I'm
always kind of like at a loss of do I
kind of give feedback as if this is all
the project is or as if it's going to
become a bigger project because
obviously like sometimes there's no need
to optimize certain things or like or
even optimize your code layout or code
structure because the app really is that
simple and it's fine the way it is you
don't need to add complexity or
abstraction by kind of moving everything
into different places it's totally fine
the way it is but if it is going to grow
and you want to kind of become a bigger
programmer or should I say a better
programmer working on bigger projects
than that kind of like feedback on
treating this as if it was a bigger
project is going to be much more
important cmax setup this was the first
time I did something else
then using the template out teacher gave
us so I would like to know if I did
anything wrong with making it we were
also using VC package and I know you
don't like that so I used fetch content
instead it's funny but I have no idea if
it's something people do in real
projects yeah I mean look I'm not a
cmake expert I tend to avoid CMAC as
much as possible I like using pre-mag
because it's just a lot simpler and
easier in my opinion to get started
cmake is kind of a little bit archaic a
little bit old school and in my opinion
just a little bit more complicated than
it needs to be and especially because 99
of the time I'm working on Windows
specifically I just like the way the
pre-make easily generates Visual Studio
Projects that are almost like vanilla in
the sense that they look like they've
been created just through vital studio
and I just really really like that
whereas with cmake you tend to get like
a lot of extra stuff that just makes it
more complex so I'm probably not gonna
be the best person to ask about cmake
now the repository link and a screenshot
Okay cool so we've got some rendering
going on which is good always good to
have like a visualizer for the physics
engine because of course the physics
engine is just numbers just math just
math happening numbers go in numbers
come out that's it no way to kind of
look at them but having some kind of
rendering obviously with sfml as as they
said is very very useful thanks a lot
for reading and have a nice day that's
nice have a nice day too alright so
here's our physics engine let's go ahead
and set it up now the thing about
writing a physics engine is that you're
going to need to know some math and like
basic physics principles where's a good
place to learn that kind of stuff you
ask just go to brilliant the sponsor of
this video brilliant is an amazing
online learning platform with so many
courses on various stem topics all of
the math that you'll need to learn to
ride this physics engine you can learn
it all on brilliant in an amazing visual
interactive and engaging way the best
thing about brilliant is that their
lessons are visual physics and math are
topics that really are best learned
visually and by engaging with them and
that's where brilliant absolutely excels
against the competition they provide you
with these amazing like visual widgets
with controls that you can manipulate to
actually see how the math is working
visually with individual lessons that
really don't take you much time so you
could spend and like 15 minutes a day
and still get this feeling of
progression and learning they've also
got a super simple introductory Everyday
Math course for those of you who have
never touched math but want to get into
it in a gentle way another great thing
with brilliant is that you can get
started for free just go to
brilliant.org the Cherno link will be in
the description below but brilliant have
also been nice enough to offer the first
200 people who sign up using my link 20
off an annual membership so definitely
check out brilliant and just get better
at math today huge thank you as always
to brilliant for sponsoring this video
alright so this is the main file that
we've got I like how clean and simple it
is we just have a nice little class
instance created here on the stack and
then we call the Run function which I'm
assuming is going to contain like a
while running Loop in it I'm also
noticing that you're using dot HPP
instead of dot h that's another way to
kind of name your header files a lot of
people like HPP because it's kind of I
guess it's like the equivalent to CPP in
a way where CPP obviously is like a c
plus plus translation unit or like
implementation file whereas dot C is
just the C programming language and
similarly people a lot of people don't
like to write.h because that that's kind
of like the equivalent dot C right
that's just a header file for C whereas
HPP specifies that it's like kind of C
plus plus specifically now me personally
I just like dot h that's just what I'm
used to but like it's a file extension
it really doesn't matter too much and of
course it's totally okay to use HPP okay
so let's take a look at this this header
file just just let's just run through
this real quick so we've got sfml
graphics cool we've got entity FPS
counter Dynamics all that stuff now this
is actually inside the demo right so we
have a couple different modules if we
just look at the project structure real
quick we've got a demo right and then
we've got the engine so it's cool to
kind of see the separation of like the
actual physics engine as a separate
module as a separate Library let's see
how this is getting compiled so it's
getting compiled as a static Library
which is pretty cool I love static
libraries because they're just it's just
so easy to work with them instead
Library by the way gets compiled like
directly into your exe file so when we
actually build like this demo.exe file
the static Library like binary data is
embedded right into the exe so you don't
need any kind of external dlls or
Library files during distribution and
packaging and all of that it's just all
within that exe file which actually
opens up a lot of really good
optimization opportunities by the Linker
and by the compiler because since it's
not like an external module like you can
just inline certain functions there's so
much stuff you can actually do that's
actually probably a good good video
topic for the future okay so this is the
class that we're kind of uh creating
over here I guess that's like the main
application class we've got a bunch of
member variables here they're all kind
of using this underscore convention
which is really cool I personally like
to use the M underscore convention like
this to indicate a member variable the
one reason why I prefer that over this
is just because you can kind of I guess
encode the type of variable this is into
the name so for example if it was static
I could use S underscore if it was maybe
a const and I wanted it to like
explicitly show up as a constant I could
type in C if it's just a normal member
variable then M right whereas with this
you kind of don't know I guess if it
maybe it's like a something that's
static kind of like this or not but in
general really really good to see that
you're doing that because in my opinion
it's just really really useful when
you're kind of going through actual code
like this to easily be able to see what
is actually part of the class what is
like a member variable versus like any
local variables that you might actually
have within this function scope okay so
what do we do in the Constructor so this
is actually calling this underscore
window Constructor so this is actually
like I guess this is like an sfml yeah
render window and so we're creating it
over here let's just pop in into the
Constructor again so video mode window
width height window name blah blah we're
just setting up the sfml window here
making an Impulse solver let's take a
look at this impulse solver so it's just
a subclass of solver cool now when
you're dealing with subclasses you'll a
lot of times you will have to kind of
create them as unique pointers because
there's something thing called what is
it like type aliasing or something
I forgot that I forgot the exact name
for it I'd probably look it up but
basically what can happen in C plus plus
is if you if you trade subclasses as not
a pointer you can't really go to the
base class and back because obviously
the like the the stack size allocation
is going to differ when you have a
pointer it doesn't matter ultimately
what it's pointing to it doesn't matter
if you have a pointer of the base class
it doesn't matter if you have a pointer
of the subclass because at the end of
the day it's still just a pointer to a
block of memory the implementation
doesn't matter in the actual data
storage of the pointer itself because
that point is always going to be 8 bytes
but when you are actually storing like
on the stack for example this entity
like this like it's being stored in this
Vector then obviously that has an actual
size and a subclass might introduce
extra member variables which will cause
that class to grow but it can't be
stored here because that size is
different does that make sense probably
worth a c plus this video on that as
well but anyway because of that we find
this kind of situation where a lot of
the times even if we wanted to kind of
store this like this I mean in this case
like theoretically you could but you
have to be really careful about how you
use it whereas if you just have a unique
pointer it doesn't matter you can cast
this to the base class you can cast this
to like a derived class it doesn't
matter it's going to work because at the
end of the day this is just a pointer to
the buffer that holds the actual real
data which would be an instance in this
case of the derived class assuming
that's how it's created I just realized
that I somehow didn't even run this code
so let's maybe run it can't believe I
didn't do that okay so here we have it
running I'm guessing this is like the
frames per second up here and oh I can
click all right that's a bit weird like
why does that just make this kind of
pillar of circles I'm guessing there's
like physics objects
right okay right click does this
apparently some controls would have been
nice like some help with the controls or
did I just not read that no I don't
think there's any instructions on
controls controls would have been good
because I have no idea how to do this
also I don't know why this isn't
resizable it's nice to make Windows
resizable
um yeah this is weird I'm maybe this is
a bug maybe it's supposed to not do that
oh I can drag it like this and that
works but if I just click
it just makes them more like that cool
all right well down to 100 FPS which I
guess is oh I'm in debug bro all right
sorry I was like judging your
performance but Warren debug let's try
build release and see uh how much faster
this guy's gonna be oh thread local.cbps
is multi-threaded yeah I guess so we've
got locks we've got mutexes cool might
have to take a look at that all right
cool so whoa
damn
look at that it would also be really
nice I mean the FPS kind of does tank a
bit uh it would be really nice it's the
thing with FPS though is you have to
remember it's not exactly linear that's
why I like milliseconds per frame would
have probably been a little bit better
but it's okay and I mean there there is
quite a lot of stuff going on here but
you can see the performance really isn't
falling below 100 FPS and I'm just like
spam creating all of these so that's
pretty cool uh it would would have also
been really nice to be able to see just
how many of these guys are actually in
the scene I'm sure that would be really
easy to add but it's kind of hard to I
have no idea how many are here
um and I can't it's kind of hard to
judge the performance I guess based on
that all right anyway let's kind of get
into more of the actual physics code
because I'm interested to take a look at
that so we create a bunch of we create
the window we create the form we create
all that stuff that's kind of boring
right the next big step is we call run
obviously which is going to contain that
while running Loop and then we I guess
we make this ABB okay so we're making an
ABB box so what is this because this is
like an entity there's some inheritance
going on I guess this is something that
we actually actually draw now you have
to remember also this is in the demo the
stuff that is kind of in the demo code
I'm expecting that to not really be the
physics engine at all that should just
be like this kind of application that
renders the physics engine it runs a
physics simulation and it renders every
single entity right so this ABB box
which of which we we seemingly create
only one of because it's just called
Ground that's just that one kind of box
and then I guess we set like a rigid
body is kinematic blah blah so this
already let's take a look at this so
this is an entity I guess wait hang on a
minute uh and we get the rigid body from
it and this rigid body
this is coming in from yet the actual
physics engine now immediately like I
mean look rigid bodies it's probably
okay to have rigid bodies set up like
this but immediately like I'm a little
bit kind of not sure about whether or
not you really do want to be using
pointers for this kind of stuff because
when you start introducing you might
have to depending on how the physics
engine is set up so this is like a very
surface level observation but in general
like just remember that
when you have pointers and when you hear
allocate in memory you end up with
memory fragmentation that means that
every time you kind of create an entity
right so this is me creating a rigid
body right what we are storing in this
kind of class is just a pointer to a
rigid body and then that points
somewhere into our memory and this is
the actual rigid body data and then if
we have something else let's just say we
had like a vector of rigid bodies
because this is just a single entity
right but you're going to have like a
vector of entities so they're all going
to contain rigid bodies that point into
completely different locations in your
memory right and the problem with that
is that when you actually need to do
some math on the rigid body data you're
going to have to read that data and if
it's just in random places in your
memory then every time the CPU is like
hey Ram I need some bytes of data it
might potentially have to read a section
of ram that it just hasn't read in a
while and if your CPU needs to just
reach for Ram that it hasn't reached for
in a while then that's what we call a
cold memory read and a cold read is
about 200 CPU Cycles
okay so your CPU might be like I don't
know three gigahertz so that's three
billion CPU cycles per second it can do
and this will take up about 200. now
contrasting to this if you have
contiguous memory meaning let's just say
these three rigid bodies that I've just
drawn in different locations here let's
just say they were all in a row so if
they were stack allocated and inside a
vector for example which by the way is
something an entity component system
would do then you would have these guys
just lined up like this next to each
other so what happens is when the CPU
needs to read that let's just say for
the first time and it requests this
memory block the CPU doesn't just read
like The bytes that you tell it to it
actually fetches like quite a bit and
this kind of extra memory that it
fetches is just going to live inside the
CPU cache and depending on how
frequently it's used and how long ago it
was requested it will exist on one of
three levels usually of CPU cache L1 L2
and L3 now L1 is like kind of a per core
really really hot but really small cash
that will contain this data and the
beauty of this is that if you're
processing this rigid body and suddenly
you're like I need this guy it's already
in the CPU cache so instead of paying
this kind of 200 cycle cost it's going
to be like one or two CPU Cycles or
something like that to just get that
memory you see the difference it's like
a hundred times faster now your mileage
May absolutely vary on all of this which
is why no matter what I tell you the
definitive test is to Benchmark and
profile potentially if you're kind of
more advanced look at the disassembly to
see exactly what's going on and you can
maybe even potentially use really like
fine grain profiling tools that will
actually tell you in Cycles how long
stuff takes you can do that and also
different Hardware different CPU
architectures may also have slightly
different kind of ways in which they
prefetch this data obviously CPU cache
sizes are going to differ offer depends
how many cores you have depends how much
shared cash there is there's this is a
very complex topic and explaining it now
is probably not going to be great I
really do want to make a video about
this like a very in-depth video about
the CPU cache in the future because it's
just such a powerful thing that can
literally improve your code speed in
like orders of magnitude it's crazy and
especially if you're building something
like a physics engine and like you're
just doing a lot of math on a lot of
actual memory a lot of actual data this
is just such an important topic now by
the way I haven't really obviously
profiled your code I've read like one
percent or ten percent of it or
something like that so I'm not in any
way saying that you've done a poor job
I'm just using this kind of unique
pointer here really as just an excuse an
example to kind of talk about this kind
of stuff and that's what I usually do
with these code reviews right I kind of
just pick out certain things that might
even not be factually accurate to this
specific project and this specific code
base but they're kind of good talking
points in general all right anyway let's
kind of move on with this so yeah so I
guess my only kind of consideration here
is just really think about like rigid
bodies and like you know does that stuff
have to be Heap allocated not not
necessarily because of the Heap
allocation cost because it is a little
bit more expensive obviously to allocate
memory on the Heap than the stack but a
lot of it has to do with actual memory
read and write not just like the
allocation cost which you might only
kind of pay once right anyway this is
just for the ground what I'm interested
in is when we press the left Mouse
button
we're spawning in a bunch of stuff so
map pixel to cores I guess gives us some
kind of world space position there's our
spawn position you look like you're
logging a lot I actually didn't even see
the log is the log even yeah there's no
log here uh maybe release mode just
doesn't like let's just see how this
sets it up yeah so this does the system
Windows which doesn't have a log debug
also does that so I'm not exactly sure
where you're logging to unless there's
another configuration that we can run
which actually spawns a log you could
also allocate a console through code of
course but anyway I didn't really see
any log or anything like that but
logging is also going to slow down stuff
so be aware of that fun fact last
weekend me and the boys did a game Jam
whilst I was testing a release build of
the final finished game no distribution
build so a release build which included
like stuff like logging and all of that
I noticed that the render thread was
taking like 20 milliseconds whereas it
really should have been taking well no
more than like maybe three or four and I
was like this was a game Jam 72 hour
game Jam I was like this is this is nuts
like I have no idea what the problem is
what's going on and then I like opened
up the console and it was just flooding
every single render command every single
render pass every draw call because I
accidentally had my renderer logging set
to trace which is like the kind of log
everything level once I disabled that we
went down from 20 milliseconds to like
two milliseconds from 20 to 2 crazy so
just just always be aware that logging
is very slow it's much faster for
example to just write to a file than it
is right to the console which is crazy I
don't know if there's like some special
thing you can do to speed it up but like
as far as I'm aware like as just a
developer especially on Windows I guess
because I just don't have maybe Linux
and Mac is faster either non-priminarily
a game developer game engine developer
so I work on Windows like 90 of the time
it's just slow terminals consoles
they're just slow and it kind of sucks
anyway so yeah I don't know if this is
doing anything considering you don't
even have a console allocated it seems
but definitely remove this stuff one
thing you can do with logging right I I
would I would always make some kind of
like logging function out of this so you
don't have to use C out but if we use
Hazel as an example so here's just like
a random Hazel engine source file this
is the script engine you can see that we
have like a log message being printed
here and you'll see that it's actually
under a macro HZ core info tag there's
some extra like formatting and
information like a tag happening here
but the concept is kind of the same it's
just gonna log a message to a console
and it'll actually also log it to a file
but why is this a macro why not make
this a function the reason why it's so
good to have these as macros is because
if you wanted to you could easily just
disable logging right imagine this
scenario in which I have this defined
and it just like I don't know it calls a
function called log message if I wanted
to I could set up using macros a little
system where if I have like you know
some kind of distribution or release
mode specified over here then I just
wouldn't do anything so it would look
something like this if not defined for
example distribution then have this
macro evaluate two calling like let's
just say this log message with this
parameter but if distribution is defined
we'll go into this branch and I could
just do this
right which will actually take this
macro including its arguments which is
like all of this stuff and replace it
with nothing it's a really really good
way to just strip code from your actual
compilation because the preprocessor
when you compile this file will look at
this and evaluate this macro and be like
oh well this evaluates to nothing so I'm
just going to Nuke this line right
there's a lot of things you could do
with this including just kind of making
code compile in certain configurations
so you could have an entire like just an
entire function or an entire like bunch
of code that just validates certain
state that could take like a few
milliseconds right but you can remove
that you can strip that from
distribution builds so your debug bills
could do just a whole bunch of extra
error checking and logging is is one
thing where you might want to implement
a system like this now we don't exactly
strip logs completely from distribution
builds inside a Hazel because we still
want to log information to a file we
stop logging it to the console for
distribution builds because that's slow
and also there is no console usually in
the actual Hazel runtime when it gets
distributed but there are still log
files where it will log certain
information usually just errors and
warnings and stuff like that so that
then kind of our users our players can
actually give us some like debug
information or maybe even themselves see
what's wrong if there is an error or a
crash or something like that okay so
yeah ultimately that's something I would
consider doing with log messages just
especially as you mentioned if this
project does become like a larger
project you're going to want to strip
these things from distribution builds
most likely or at least change it so
that it logs just to a file and doesn't
kind of affect your performance too much
but yeah I guess what we do here is you
can see that this happens every frame
right so we pull events here whatever
don't care about that in this while loop
if the mouse is pressed every frame we
are going to push back a heap allocated
object that's a little bit unfortunate
what I would do at the very least right
sure you might need to actually
dynamically allocate it might not be
able to be in the stack I don't care you
you should consider some kind of arena
allocator for this what is an arena
allocator basically what you do is you
just set up
some kind of pre-allocated block of
memory and it could be pretty big yeah
it could be 10 Meg a 10 Meg doesn't
sound like a lot but obviously for
circles which probably don't like I
would normally imagine this is above 100
bytes per Circle right this is this
translates to quite a lot because 10
megabytes is literally 10 million bytes
so 10 million bytes divided by 100 gives
you like you know quite a lot of circles
a hundred thousand but don't forget if
you exceed that 10 Meg you can also like
add 50 or just double it right and then
you can have 20 meg so it's it's fine to
kind of do that but the idea is if you
predefine this block of memory there are
two advantages to this first of all
allocating a new circle is very quick
right because basically what happens is
you could run this kind of like a stack
allocator or a linear allocator where
basically you just have a pointer to
where you're up to in this buffer and
every time you want a new Circle you
kind of just grab that right now with
freeing memory that can get a little bit
trickier for this kind of Stack color
header example because if this circle
completely dies then you'll have a hole
here you might have to like defragment
it or there's a bunch of stuff you could
do but let's just stick with a simple
example every time you need a circle you
just allocate it and you just keep track
of where you are here so allocating is
as simple as just let me get let me grab
the current memory address move that
pointer by the size of the allocation
which could be like 100 bytes yeah so
now the point is here but you return
that pointer before you moved it and
that's it you just return that pointer
and that's your block of memory that is
100 bytes large and you can use for
whatever you want amazing right so
there's two benefits here allocation as
you see is very fast you just return the
current pointer and like you know
increment the existing pointer by 100
bytes at the next allocation will be at
a free block of memory but not only is
allocating fast
iterating through this is going to be
very fast as well because guess what
this 10 megabytes is going to be
contiguous right so that fragmentation I
was talking about where memory is just
in random locations that won't be a
thing here because you're going to have
10 megabytes all in a row like this
right now it might not exactly be in a
row especially if it's a large block of
memory because we have this thing called
virtual memory and actual Ram might be a
bit more like the physical RAM might
actually be a bit more fragmented even
though your memory addresses are going
to be contiguous which is why like you
know if you're really relying on this
there's a bunch of stuff you can do and
you should do but again keeping it
simple you can see that this will kind
of give us a contiguous asterisk block
of memory and it will be much better
than uh than kind of just allocating
randomly from the Heap so Arena
allocator
yeah look into like using memory Arenas
you can also use uh you can also have
like a stack allocator that use for
transient Frame data so what that means
is that like you know there there's a
lot of kind of there are there are so
many scenarios in which a game engine or
even like this application might want to
allocate memory but the memory only
exists for the lifetime of a single
frame in that case it's really easy to
deal with because if the memory lifetime
is so predictable that it's just kind of
tied to the duration of a frame you can
just reset it every frame so you reset
it at the beginning of the frame and
then you just allocate into it and then
you don't have to worry about freeing
each individual block or anything like
that because you just move the pointer
back to the start for the next frame and
that's it because the memory in that
case is guaranteed not to be used after
a frame ends so you can just kind of
reset it and keep kind of allocating
within that block of memory you started
over here allocate allocate allocate
allocate all the frames over we move
back here and then next frame we
allocate allocate allocate allocate
allocate and move it back you know frame
three allocate allocate allocate
allocate you get the point right really
really easy and it also performs
amazingly well which is great okay so
kind of a lot of memory kind of uh I
guess tips I would give over here all
right then we do World step
um
apply gravity resolve collisions to be
honest like I love looking at things
like this physics engine because it's
there's just so much here to kind of
dissect and talk about like it's just a
really kind of it's just a really good
example of scale right because you could
really scale this up to have like
Millions potentially of objects
colliding I mean by then by that stage
you'd probably have to move it to like
the GPU or something like that because
that kind of parallel processing is
really going to help but it's such a
good use case that I'm honestly
considering splitting this up into
multiple videos like I might just talk
about something else because I've just
really been talking about memory today
uh and I haven't actually talked about
the math or the actual physics engine
itself but yeah so far I'm just kind of
noticing the fact that yeah you have
circles you have abbs added with the
left and right Mouse button However the
fact that they're kind of you know
allocated on the Heap using unique
pointers here that could really really
be be improved and I think that would
actually make quite a big difference
even though you're already performing
pretty well which is great to see what I
want to quickly take a look at before we
probably wrap this up for today is I
want to take a look at how the okay so
we have forces here sure we're using
that new kind of C plus 20 API which to
me just looks kind of dodgy but sure
um going through like all of these
bodies that's cool I want to see if we
do actual multi-threading here because I
did notice that you had some kind of uh
or maybe not actually maybe that was
just in like sfml those thread files
because I was gonna I was gonna say if
you have yeah I think they're an sfml
system that's a shame I thought you had
some actual multi-threading going on
here because that would have been really
cool to look at but uh I guess it is
what it is okay so resolve collisions
with Delta time uh Vector for the
collisions that have been detected yeah
see this kind of stuff I don't like
either because what we're doing here is
we're again vectors are Dynamic arrays
they're arrays that can resize and they
they store all of their memory as a heap
allocated block but another thing that
happens is they start off like you know
you're not kind of defining a starting
size for this buffer of memory instead
of what you do is you go through all the
Collision Pairs and every time there's a
collision you just in place back and
what that does is it forces the vector
potentially to resize and when it
resizes it has to allocate a new block
of memory and then typically we'll
either like copy or move the data I mean
in this case moving it's probably not
going to really help much because you're
just storing collisions which is just
stack objects anyway actually no these
are Pointers oh no but they're just
point us to existing parties so yeah
it's all kind of Stack objects so it's
just going to copy that memory block
from the old Vector into the new vector
and you're going to get your elements
kind of all being copied across but the
thing is when you go through this
first of all you know how many Collision
pairs there are even though it kind of
depends on if it's a trigger whether or
not it goes into triggers or collisions
you roughly know how many there are so
what I would do at the very least is
reserve a memory block that is big
enough to at least kind of store this
stuff right because what will happen is
Vector when when Vector needs to
allocate memory it will add on 50
percent of what the capacity is so if we
actually look it in place back and see
what it does right so in place one at
back in place reallocate and then if you
take a look at this so all size equals
Max size blah blah new capacity
calculate grow right so new size is
going to be all size plus one because
we're adding a single element in this
case nuke capacity calculate growth and
if we take a look at this check out what
it does it does old capacity Plus old
capacity divided by two so what it's
actually doing is growing it by 50 if
there were eight elements there there
are now going to be enough room for 12
elements so we get a 50 kind of growth
and you can imagine that if we're going
through this and there's like you know
as many entities as I had there in that
test where we had like maybe hundreds
thousands whatever how many times do you
think this guy's allocating like so many
times and that's happening every frame
when we're resolving collisions again
much better to already have maybe a
pre-allocated block you can actually
pass in your own allocator into the
vector class that you've made yourself
that has a pre-allocated block of memory
like a stack allocator or some kind of
memory Arena that you're allocating from
and that will work and that will work
much faster because again it doesn't
really it's not that big of a deal to
grow but the best scenario here is if
you just have enough memory
pre-allocated so that you don't have to
ever reallocate during like this that
will just be be better so that's one
immediate thing that I'm noticing over
here then we do solve collisions which
again all these pointers everywhere and
then we do solve and there's a few
different solvers and I think that's
probably something that we're going to
get into in depth next time all right to
be honest I enjoyed this this code base
and this code review so much the code
itself is really clean I love the
conventions you've used I love the like
just the the comments you know that
you've left here I mean there are some
things like I would drop this into a
into this line or whatever but in
general code is really easy to read
really clean so really good job story I
honestly think you've done a really good
job here but there are just some kind of
optimizations that I would definitely
add and honestly I'm I'm so happy with
this code base that I think I'm going to
make a follow-up video which I've never
done in a code review episode before but
I think I want to make a follow-up video
and we're going to dive a little bit
deeper into the actual physics things
and we might even if I have time to do
this I would love to implement some of
these organizations do some profiling
see the difference I think that'll be a
really good exercise anyway thank you
guys for watching this code review hope
you did enjoy it please don't forget to
hit the like button if you did leave
your thoughts and maybe there's certain
things you disagree with that I said
maybe you have extra suggestions leave
all that in the comments section below
if you would like to send in your code
for me to take a look at then send me an
email to channelreview gmail.com there
are some instructions in the description
below and while you're there check out
brilliant it's honestly such an amazing
learning platform to just learn math and
physics and just exciting stuff thank
you guys for watching I'll see you next
time goodbye
foreign
[Music]